all right guys bang bang I've got Darius
here uh Darius a great place to start is
let's just talk about the economy some
people think it's hot some people think
it's cool some people think the fet cut
interest rates some people think the FED
is doing a perfect job but before we get
to what we think they should do let's
dig into some data low worker turnover
is this huge uh you know talking point
now and you're saying that it's
supportive of an economic expansion
explain yeah absolutely so thanks for
having me as always great to be here uh
so this chart where we show uh Joe's
total job openings divided by total
unemploy workers that's that all
important ratio uh that JP has been
guiding us to as as an indication of how
much slack or or tightness is exhibits
in the labor market in the second panel
there we showed the private sector
highers rate uh at 3.9% was unchanged
month over month in the month of
December that's a below Trend rate
relative to the 2015 and 2019 Trend
third panel there we show the private
sector's quits rate uh which declined at
2.4 percent which is the uh exactly the
same number it trended at prior to the
pandemic and the reason that's important
is because when we see lower turnover as
we've seen in recent quarters uh it is
supportive of the economic expansion
because it takes the pressure off of
wages uh in terms of the labor
market now when we see this turnover I
also just saw that there was uh payroll
growth is coming in under
expectations and so how much of this is
um mixed
signals compared to no some of these
data points are actually more important
than others like this next chart you
have is workers that change jobs or
experience faster wage growth and so as
we dig into this kind of worker data
what do you put you know heavy emphasis
on versus maybe some of the data points
you ignore yeah absolutely so I think we
do a really good job for our clients at
42 macro of contextualizing all the
things that matter within the context of
all the various reports that we get out
of the US Labor Market uh it's been a
massive week for labor market data in
particular on Tuesday we got the jolts
report on Tuesday yesterday we got the
consumer confidence Bor consumer
confidence report there are labor market
surveys uh embedded in that today we got
the employment cost index uh and the ADP
uh uh employment report tomorrow we get
job as claims and then Friday we get uh
the actual job support so uh in terms of
focusing investors on kind of the the
general lay of the land like what what's
actually happening in the labor market
and then we can drill down into the
chart specifically you know the labor
market is cooling but it is not crashing
and cooling but not crashing is actually
supportive for risk it's it's supporting
of this elevated probability of a soft
Landing in the US economy that is
underpinning the current Goldilocks
Market regime so let's get into this uh
chart here number two uh we say workers
that change jobs experience faster wage
growth that's something that we observed
in both the ADP median annual pay
statistics we also observe that in the
Atlanta fed wage growth tracker
statistics as well that's the blue line
for uh the the growth rate of wages for
workers that change jobs relative to the
red lines which are the growth rate of
wages for workers that stay at their
jobs so uh going back to that first
chart where we show the private sector
highers rate and the private sector
quits rate are now below Trend and at
Trend respectively having declined over
the past several quarters it's
suggesting that we're going to continue
to see slower wage growth wage
disinflation in the months ahead which
is obviously supportive of the rate uh
uh uh cuts that are projected and priced
into money markets now labor hoarding I
never even heard of that before what
what is labor hoarding and what is that
telling us yeah so the reason you've
never heard of Labor hoarding before
because it hasn't happened throughout
our careers uh for the most part we saw
a little bit of Labor Hoarding in 2018
to 2019 but really it's been a
post-pandemic uh excess fiscal excess
monetary stimulus phenomenon uh that has
really uh that has really guided the US
economy and asset markets over the past
few years so what we mean by labor
hoarding is is uh uh labor demand just
simply outstripping labor Supply uh so
in this chart on slide three here uh we
show the total labor force in the top
panel which is still below Trend
relative to the 20 2009 to 2019 trend we
show gross domestic income uh on a
nominal basis which is well above Trend
and has been since 2021 and then the
third panel we show labor demand uh
which is household survey total
Employment Plus jol's total job openings
that's the blue line at about 170
million and then we show labor Supply
which is again the labor for the total
labor force which is at about 167
million the third panel where we show
our labor demand minus labor Supply
metric that number is running at 2.7 uh
uh 2.76 million in terms of excess uh uh
unit of demand relative to units of
supply of labor here in the US economy
that's obviously really uh important
because it's obviously caus is one of
those contributing factors uh to
elevated or slightly above Trend uh sort
of wage growth and so the the FI the
bottom panel there we just um you know
we show uh we break out labor demand uh
in terms of household survey employment
the Blue Line uh and total job openings
uh the red line and and what we see is
that the red line has been the only uh
uh statistic responsible for generating
the lack in the labor market uh that
we've observed in the past couple of
years recall that the spread between
labor Supply uh sorry labor demand and
labor Supply peaked at right around just
north of 5 million uh in in the in the
first quarter of 2022 and is obviously
declined again towards 2.8 million uh
currently so all that slack that we've
created in the labor market has really
come at the expense of the red line in
the bottom panel there which is total
job openings we have not seen a
broad-based decline in total employment
which is why we continue to call it
labor hoarding companies are willing to
take down job openings and slow the rate
of of wage growth but they're not
willing to fire people which obviously
would cause a recession so in our
opinion we think this Dynamic is
persistent is likely to persist uh
because at worst corporate executives
are only anticipating a shallow
recession I would argue that you know
just based on consumer and business
confidence metrics that that expectation
of a shallow recession is actually
moving in a positive manner towards
expecting a soft Landing uh and the
sustainability of the business cycle now
you say shallow recession um it feels
like a lot of people just expect the
recession to come we can go through a
whole bunch of data points as to why
they're expecting that um but this other
slide you have is saying that there's a
number of indicators you guys are
watching that shows a low probability of
a recession so it feels like the
mainstream conversation is of course a
recessions coming how severe will it be
but maybe you're saying something else
might happen yeah absolutely so uh in
our opinion the probability of a soft
Landing Remains the highest probability
outcome in the US economy uh we are not
in the soft Landing Camp we're not in
the no Landing Camp we're not in the
hard Landing Camp we're in the camp that
allows us and our clients at 42 macro to
make money and we've been in the soft
Landing Camp we've been renting the soft
Landing Camp since November 1st of last
year in terms of anticipating and
calling for a self Landing Goldilocks
trade So that obviously was a spot on in
terms of uh in terms of helping our
clients profit from that from that view
uh in terms of this chart here our fab
five recession signaling indicators and
these are handpicked time series from
you know dozens and dozens if not
hundreds of Time series that we analyzed
that uh that and ultimately uh give
investors the best lead time with Sport
with respect to reporting and also the
most consistency with respect to
accuracy of predicting uh uh predicting
rising or falling probability of a
developing recession uh here in the US
economy uh so uh I mentioned uh we got
the conference board uh uh consumer
confidence index yesterday uh the labor
survey differential uh within the
context of that report ticked up uh uh
by 8.4 points month- over month in
January which is the fastest
month-over-month Delta we have seen in
that time series since I want to say may
of 2021 uh and so we're obviously moving
in the wrong direction from the
perspective of anyone who is positioning
for uh a hard Landing or is anticipating
a hard Landing outcome and so brought in
in mass of these five data points the
only temporary employment uh in terms of
the three-month annual eyes rate of
change there ofus
13.3% only one of these five uh is
signaling a high probability of a
developing recession three are signaling
a low probability and one is signaling a
middling probability so in Balance we
don't think there's a tremendous amount
of risk uh of a hard Landing here in the
US economy because the leading
indicators that we have hand selected
based on our our our careful research
and and and and understanding of these
critical economic Dynamics um that
support that suggest that you know
recession is not really something that
we need to be concerned about as
investors now let's say that a recession
is not something we need to be concerned
about then obviously we probably should
keep interest rates where are do you
think that we should be hiking them I
would actually argue that maybe we
should be cutting interest rates not a
lot maybe like 25 basis points with an
eye to do like 50 to 75 basis points
throughout the year uh as a way to kind
of start easing back uh so we don't
overshoot but how are you thinking about
if you're you know the FED chairman and
you got to make these interest rate
decisions given the data that you've got
and the low probability of recession
that you're seeing do you just leave
them where they are this episode is
brought to you by bet online do you like
making a profit from sports betting well
set yourself up to take home the most
profit possible using crypto to fund
your sports betting casino and poker
account at
betonline.ag you can avoid costly
transaction fees get your payouts
lightning fast and do it all securely
and anonymously with the highest deposit
and withdrawal limits in the industry if
you want to get in on the action do it
the smart way with crypto at
betonline.ag head to the website sign up
with promo code pomp 100 to get 100%
bonus on your crypto deposit today if
you go and you deposit they'll give you
100% bonus you use promo code pomp 100
bet online the game starts here
betonline.ag go check them out today
yeah great minds think Alik my friend
the FED uh in December acknowledged the
the Market's pricing of rate Cuts uh
throughout 2024 and into uh over the
next couple of years uh and then in my
opinion that that's very warranted uh
given exactly what you said which is
they should be reversing course to avoid
overshooting and overtightening the
economy uh recall that the FED thinks
about policy its policy rate rate from
the perspective of the real rate not
perspective of the nominal rate and
right now we continue to see very
obvious signs of inflation crashing
lower um if you go back to Friday's uh
PC report for the month of December uh
we got core pce in that report uh both
the three-month annualized and six-month
annualized rates of change of core pce
the fed's preferred inflation gauge are
at or below 2% and so you know with that
or below 2% is obviously well off the 3
to four to 5% uh rates of uh rates of
inflation that we observed in in the
last few years when the Fed was you know
anxiously tightening policy at the
fastest Pace in 40 years so uh now that
we are seeing pretty uh pretty clear and
obvious signs that inflation is likely
to continue trending lower on a
year-over-year basis over the medium
term it's is a signal to us as investors
but also to the FED as policy makers
that they actually do need to tone down
the the nominal level of the policy rate
uh just to maintain the same real rate
as inflation continues to come lower so
in our view it's good policy uh it's
it's it's it's piggybacking on the great
policy that we continue to observe out
of the uh treasury uh the treasur we got
the QR way qra this week at the C
funding announcement and um the coupon
auction size is surpris to the downside
the net financing surprise to the
downside bond issue is continues to be
well subdued um you know if you look at
their cash balance estimates for into
quarter q1 into quarter Q2 uh the TGA is
above that which implies right around
$100 billion of fresh liquidity waiting
to be pumped into the system you know so
there there's a lot of really positive
dynamics that are uh sort of uh being
pumped in asset markets from the
perspective of monetary and fiscal
policy here in the US and guess what
it's for good reason it's for all the
reasons we identified uh going back to
um you know late October early November
of last year in terms of accelerated
Immaculate disinflation uh evidence of a
resilient US economy uh persisting but a
cooling but not crashing labor market
that is ultimately taking the winds uh
started taking pressure out of Corp wage
growth which obviously is is supportive
and a guiding feature for all these
positive Dynamics now when you see the
FED uh as one component we also have the
politicians on the other side and
they're just they lost their minds
they're printing money they're dropping
fiscal stimulus from every corner that
they got um proxy wars uh infrastructure
Bill chips act name all the other crazy
things that they want to do uh should
the FED consider those inputs into the
economy and can they somehow predict
what the politicians are going to do in
that changing their monetary policy
decisions like it almost feels like in
2020 they were on the same page cut
rates print money now it feels like the
Fed was like let's tighten and the
politicians were like screw you guys
this is too much fun let's just keep you
know pushing money into the economy so
how do you think about the relationship
between the politicians and fiscal
versus the central banks and uh the
monetary policy yeah no I think they're
getting increasingly less correlated um
to your point um if you think about
what's happening with fiscal policy here
in the US we continue to observe a very
positive fiscal impulse albeit getting
less positive at the margins and less
positive at the margins is a negative uh
sort of um signal for the economy and
ultimately for asset markets I think we
discussed that uh the last time I was on
with respect to the change in our macro
weather model signal for for the stock
market for instance uh going from
bullish to neutral with respect to the
rolling three Monon forward uh Outlook
um so that's that's something at the
margin that we are observing like if you
look at the uh the year-over-year
nominal Delta of the federal budget
deficit it's up about $320 billion
year-over-year in the month of December
that's down from up being up about $835
billion year of year in June right so
like we are pumping a tremendous amount
of money uh into the economy Visa the
federal budget deficit uh then we are
still pumping money uh more money into
the economy Vis the federal budget
deficit on a year-over-year basis it's
just a lot smaller than it had been uh
but again still positive the fiscal
impulse is still positive it's just not
as positive as it as it was and and we
obviously have a an election we're it's
an election general election year you
know we're not going to I don't think
anybody wants to hear you or me talk
about participate pontificate about
what's going to happen in the election
but the one thing I will say is we've
done obviously as always a tremendous
amount of work and trying to help
investors clients uh understand and
ultimately position and profit from you
know some of these critical Dynamics uh
one thing we not is that stock markets
usually does really well uh in an
election year especially when a Democrat
uh is an incumbent president on the Bel
uh obviously Joe Biden is not going to
uh for for you know if if Joe Biden's
going to lose the race it's not going to
be because he didn't try uh in terms of
spending uh uh fiscal spending and and
pumping money and funds into the economy
Vis the chips act the inflation
reduction act I think there's another
act as well but the the at the end of
the day uh you should be expecting these
kinds of positive fiscal impulse
Dynamics you should be expecting uh
positive monetary policy Dynamics just
based on what's happening in the economy
so um you know just kind of summarizing
all this a lot of bears have just been
wrong about you know kind of right down
the middle of the Fairway stuff monetary
policy fiscal policy
growth inflation you can't afford to get
these things wrong as an investor and in
my opinion I think the reason a lot of
investors have gotten these things wrong
over the past two to three years is
because they're spending entirely too
much time on Twitter that's not an
investment process it just
isn't now we've got over the last one
year the S&P is up 20% uh year to date
it's up about 3% NASDAQ had a monster
year last year what is your expectations
given where the economy is low
probability of recession Federal Reserve
is going to do what it's going to do are
you expecting this to be another monster
year for kind of tech and and
magnificent 7 Etc or do you think that
this will kind of be a reversion back to
maybe more of the historical type
returns you know in that like six to 10
per uh for for the stock market yeah
probably the latter um you know there's
a lot of you know very positive
Tailwinds uh you know supporting asset
markets here but the starting point of
underp positioned investors and and and
you know kind of reasonable valuations
just don't exist like they existed uh
the beginning of last year now that's
not to say that uh we're bearish or
there's any uh negative things that
really hit the tape yet you know one of
the things I think we do uh uh as you
know on on a very institutional high-end
buy sight level for our clients of 42
macro that most saleside research
providers don't do is you know sort of a
Daily basian Grind through all the
information and through all the the
models that that really um we need to be
AB breast of as investors to make you
know important critical pivots in our
portfolio and you know we continue to
refresh the same models every day six
days a week here 42 macro we continue to
analyze the same data sets every single
month every time it's the J's report
comes out the conference report comes
out the unit labor cost comes out
productivity comes out we analyze those
exact same data points month after month
after month after month quarter after
quarter after quarter after quarter so
that we can spot critical inflections in
real time and the reality is we have not
seen any fundamental data point you know
critically inflect in a way that would
be materially threatening to the current
Goldilocks top down Market regime now
that doesn't mean it is not coming it
may come tomorrow in in the form of a
really negative outcome in terms of the
Q4 productivity report or the unit labor
cost data it may come in the form of an
adverse outcome uh in the form of of of
a Friday's January jobs report we also
have meta earnings we I think we have
Amazon earnings tonight we got Apple
earnings of tomorrow on Friday so
there's a lot of information between now
and you know kind of 4M Friday uh uh
Friday afternoon that suggest that you
know what I just said about the
fundamental uh the positive fundamental
developments changing at the bargins but
until they change and Andor until our
medium-term quantitative risk management
signals say that you know goil loocks
has a low probability of surviving we're
not going to change we're going to
continue to be bullish so obviously you
can check our clients will check back
with us tomorrow for those
updates where can we send people to find
you on the internet or find out more
about 42 macro well only if they like
making money if they like making money
definitely come to 42 macro.com if you
don't like making money then God help
you uh I have you know just follow me on
Twitter Darius Dell at 42 is my Twitter
account I always appreciate it man I
learned something and I appreciate your
balanced approach to uh whether we're
going to have a recession or not as you
see more and more soft Landing
commentary come up uh usually that is
not a good sign
but I know we would wrap it up but let's
let's I I do want to leave on this uh I
think you brought up a good point right
the if we look at our positioning model
you know one of the things we track we
track a variety of the different
indicators in our positioning model
whether it be valuation whether it be uh
positioning survey based or hard
positioning the cftc report uh we track
uh you investor allocations via the AI
survey so we're we're constantly
monitoring positioning in the context of
those long-term time series so that we
could spot you know sort of extreme
values that would signal uh it's a good
time to take the other side of a trade
or calling for a p pain trade we call
for the pain trade higher at the
beginning of November in the context of
the soft Landing uh uh signals that we
got from the economy right now we are
starting to get some elements of our
positioning model that suggest now is a
good time to be tactically reducing a
market risk that doesn't necess say mean
Goldie Locks is about to end from a
medium-term perspective you know 3 four
five six months but it does suggest that
you know we could get a pullback here uh
a correction in stocks you know in the
order of 58% which is very normal very
healthy and I don't think anybody should
um you know kind of lose any sleep over
something like that I love it all right
we'll definitely do it again in about
two weeks so let's uh let's hope that
nothing crazy happens between now and
then absolutely but hope hope is not an
investment strategy it's not a risk
management process 42 macro is a risk
management process